RAM RAMANATHAN:
Welcome everybody.
Looks like we- I hope they
know to let more people in,
but welcome everybody.
Ram Ramanathan, Product
Manager at Google Cloud.
Along with me, I
have Juhyun Lee,
who a software engineer in
our research organization.
And also with me,
we have Lynn Urwitz,
who IS a developer at one our
favorite customers, fix.com.
So the goal for the
session is to help
you find cats in videos.
That's really all we're going to
talk about video intelligence.
How can you find your next cat
video as easily as possible?
Because as you guys
know, the internet
is all about cat videos.
And so, the thing that
we're trying to talk about
is, jokes apart, the
goal for this is really
think about how can we
make sense of dark content,
as [INAUDIBLE] put it.
How do you find a favorite,
your relevant entities,
and video content?
How can we help you
find potentially,
if you're thinking about
a media organization.
Like an example is how Google
Play can automatically detect
appropriate actors, actresses
in videos, et cetera.
How can we help you do
those kind of scenarios?
Video content it's
exploding every day, right?
I think it was an
article last week
talking about how every
day people watch over
a billion hours of video
content on YouTube.
Every day.
And can you imagine-
and there's an article
in Cisco- Cisco actually had an
article sometime back talking
about how by 2020, 60% to 70%
of all traffic on the internet
is going to be video content.
Well, how do you
make sense of that?
How can you, as an
organization, start
harnessing all this video
content that's flowing through?
Sometimes content that
you're publishing,
content that you have access
to, and sometimes it's content
that you're distributing.
How can you make sense
of this media content,
so you can get metadata and
do things with that content.
Clearly, people have
been doing things
with structured data
for a long time, right?
You know VI and data warehousing
has been in the marketplace,
people know what to do with
VI and data warehousing.
How do I think
about querying data?
How do I find relevant entities?
How do I walk through
a lot of these pieces?
Largest aspect of something
that people do already
in structured data.
But for the most part,
video content as being
something dark.
People have not
really played with it,
outside of consuming it.
And really, the goal
for this session
is how do we enable
you to do that.
For example, how do you
find your favorite dog
in a consumer video?
Or how do you find a
video of a sports event
across your petabytes
of video content
if you're a media organization?
How can we enable
you to do that?
And that's really what
we're going to spend
some time talking about.
Another aspect that you guys
can imagine more and more,
is more and more video content
and not actually professionally
created content, but it's
actually crowd created content.
Same way as images have
exploded on mobile cameras,
people are now creating more and
more videos on mobile devices.
So we want to start
understanding this content
from these devices.
And so you can start driving
better recommendations,
better [? hat ?] targeting,
et cetera, et cetera.
And that's really the
goal is, how do we
do that with video content?
So Google provides a
pretty broad platform
for machine learning.
We'll spend a couple
of cycles on this
so you guys get
the context of what
are we talking about today.
So as an organization,
one aspect
is we provide you a
platform that you can build
your data to Google Cloud.
You have a set of
data scientists
in your organization.
They can then build their
own machine learning module
using TensorFlow,
and then we provide
you a managed service runtime
using our cloud ML engine.
So the case on
the left is really
your data, your model graph,
running on cloud ML using
an open source framework.
The one on the right
is really thinking
about how we can use some of
our own Google internal models-
like our apply the [? rate ?]
targeted scenarios,
and in how you can use
that to harness that.
So it's really targeted
more app developers.
So basically in the
case for vision,
we've used models
that power things
like image search, models
that power things like
Google Photos.
We've exposed that as an API.
And so basically
you consume that
with minimal customization.
And so the new
[INAUDIBLE] API we
want to spend some
time talking about
is our Video Intelligence API.
So Video Intelligence
API is all about how
you can help use Google models
that power all first party
Google products like
YouTube, Google Photos.
And how you can harness
the same technology
for your own unique scenario.
So what are the key
use cases that we're
trying to solve for
Video Intelligence?
Really we're thinking
about three main things.
How do you find the main topics
of what the video is about?
So for example, what
is a video about?
What are the key relevant
entities within the video?
So those are really
what-- just kind
of thing of the
fundamental use case
that we're trying
to solve for first.
The second big use case is, if
anything vision has taught me,
is many organizations
really want
to monitor
inappropriate content.
Especially if you think about
your crowd-sourced platform
and there's a lot of
people uploading content
into that device.
How do you monitor and manage
what inappropriate content
that flows through?
And that's a key
use case that people
have to deal with, especially
in Cloud [INAUDIBLE]
crowd-sourced content.
And the third part
is how do we find
the most relevant
moments in a video
so you can start publishing it?
Unlike a document,
unlike an image,
if you have a 10
minute long video,
how do you entice somebody
to watch that video, right?
So really thinking
about highlights
and thinking about
video previews.
It's a pretty key problem
in the video use case.
And that's another scenario
we'll talk a little bit about.
So really key, the
three part things
we are going to
talk about, is how
do you find the right
entity in the video
or what the video
is about, how do
we moderate
inappropriate content,
and how you think
about finding the best
moments within the video.
So let's start off
with the first aspect,
how do you find entities?
So really we have a feature
in the Video Intelligence
API called label detection.
So label detection
is basically--
if you have label
detection on vision,
this applies
primarily on images.
I mean, now we have label
detection on video content.
So really its goal is to
find thousands and thousands
of different entities
in video content.
These entities can be
things like everyday objects
from chairs, to
things, to activities
like running, jumping, falling.
Or even things like
scenarios like how
do you think about
everyday objects like cars,
transportation, et cetera.
And we'll talk a little bit
about those entities later.
And how do you call this API?
So really the thing is
you're passing the URI, which
is basically a GCS location, a
Google Cloud Storage location
for where the video is.
And then you can
also tell it where
do you want to
write the output to.
So it's really--
the one caveat I
want to make sure you guys
leave with, in V1 we're
really focused on
back scenarios and not
real time streaming scenarios.
So really it's whereas you
have a piece of video content
on Google Cloud Storage
that we read from
and then we write back to.
So there are lots of
other streaming scenarios
that you can imagine that we're
not solving for that in V1,
still it's something we're
thinking about down the line
for future versions.
And the other part that we
want to spend some time on
is I'll talk a
little bit about is
what do you want
to see in a video,
and when do you want
to see the video.
So we give you a
couple of aspects.
We give you things like video
level annotation that tells you
this video is about blah.
Right?
So what is this video about?
And then the second part
is when in the video
did something occur?
And for that there are
different ways you can do that.
There are things called-- what
we have called shot mode that
tells you tell me things
relevant to the shot,
and the things that are
relevant at a frame level, which
is basically just applying
Vision API on a frame
by frame perspective.
And we'll talk a little bit
about the differences in when
you would use A versus B.
So the response
that you get back,
and I'm going to spend
some time on this.
Really, the thing that
you get back from us,
it will tell you the entity,
so what the entity is about.
Right now all the entities
are written in English.
Our goal over time is to
support additional languages.
And then we tell you where in
the video something occurred.
So we tell you first the level,
whether it's a video level
entity.
Meaning this entity
really defines
what the video is about,
or whether this video
occurs at a certain shot.
In which case we tell you
the start and end time,
or just we tell you--
if you want to do a
frame level entity,
we'll tell you it occurs
at a certain frame.
And one of the things
I want to spend
some time more on over
the next few slides
is why do we give
you so many options.
Because understanding
video content
can be a little
complicated, and that's
the reason why we give you all
these different permutations
of content coming back at you.
So the first thing we
talk about is how do you
separate signal from noise.
That's one of the
reasons why we do this.
Because the challenge
with video content
is if you run an
hour long video with,
let's say, a shot
changes every minute.
That's meaning that
the camera angle
goes from looking like
this or looking like this.
So can you imagine
that's a shot change,
the entire camera changes.
Those kinds of scenarios, if you
think about an hour long video,
which changes every
hour, every minute,
so that's roughly
60 shots, right?
The question is, what do you
want to understand out of that?
So it depends on
level of granularity,
depending on use
case-- you guys,
people think of
different things.
So the first thing we do is we
give you a video level entity.
So what is it good for?
So it's really
focused around this
is kind of truly where we
talk about more than just
a frame level annotation.
Meaning that we just don't use
Vision API to look at something
and give you results.
We're actually doing additional
machine learning logic
on top of each frame.
And Juhyun is going to
spend some time about that.
But one of the
caveats is this really
applies only when the entire
video is about a certain thing.
And it's really
optimized for scenarios
where it's shot from content
minimally one to five minutes.
So if you give us
a hour long TV show
and you say, hey, give me
this video level entity,
it's going to give you a very
high level generic entities.
And that's something
you guys should
be aware of, because
video level annotations
it really makes sense more
for shot from content.
The other aspect is
shot level annotations.
So think of a shot
as a mini video,
meaning that's kind
of grouped together
based on the shot change and
so almost as a mini video.
And this is kind of a first
level temporal entity.
So will tell you
when in the video
something occurred and will kind
of group it at the shot level.
So it will tell you just start
and end time of the shot,
and within that
shot we'll tell you
these are the most relevant
entities in that shot.
So where does that
kind of come into play?
You can imagine especially
when you have like,
let's say, you have
an hour long TV show.
You really want to--
there's going to be a lot of
context switching in that TV
show, right?
People are going to be-- some
people are going to be suddenly
talking inside, people are
going to be going outside.
Each shot has a different
set of relevant entities
and what you really care
about tell me exactly
what's relevant within a shot.
Because otherwise
you're going to be
dealing with a lot of
noise coming at you.
Because, for example, we'll
talk a little bit about an event
later where, for example-- we
have it in a video-- but say
I am talking right now.
And if somebody does a
frame level annotation
they literally are going to
get the same set of entities
every frame every second.
That's a lot of noise
coming back at you, right?
So that's really
where shots really
help you there because it's
going to basically aggregate
that information
and say, hey, guess
what this is what's really
relevant within this video.
So you're not dealing with all
that noise coming back at you.
That's why it kind of goes
back to separating signal
from noise.
And the other value is
that over time we also
can start adding
additional signals.
So you can start adding more
than just visual signals,
additional signals can
flow in and tell you
what the shot is about.
And Juhyun will cover a
little bit about that later.
So this is where we
can-- so this is really
thinking about things
about context switching.
So think about new
shows, TV shows.
Think about aspects,
like for example,
even like basically the video
we showed at the keynote demo
Sarah did.
Like an ad as multiple
different context switching.
A shot based entity would be
very relevant in that scenario.
And finally we have the
lowest level of granularity,
which is frame level.
So frame level is really
thinking about there's
no additional ML logic.
It's really just banging,
taking every frame at one FPF.
And you're banging
against a image detector
and saying, hey what do you
see in this frame of the video.
So there's a little less logic,
a little less intelligence
in this aspect, but there
are a lot of scenarios
where this makes sense.
For example, there's a lot of
scenarios in, say, surveillance
where the video is
not moving, it's
always pointing in
a certain direction.
And which case if
I do a shot change,
there is no shot change there's
just always one shot, right?
So at that base, frame level
entities make a lot more sense.
The other thing is
consumer videos.
For example, if it's a long
form video where you really
want to get a
different-- you want
to understand exactly
what's happening
at a much more granular level
than even at the shot level.
Some of these frame level
entities make sense.
So this is cloud.
And I kept reading
a lot of tweets
yesterday saying there was not
enough demos of the keynotes.
So the goal today is to
show you guys some demos.
So if we switch to
my demo machine,
and if I can actually log in.
OK.
So by the way the whole
goal for this session
is how do I get
back to BigQuery.
Because I love BigQuery
so my goal is in the end
I'm going to end up
back in BigQuery.
So let's first go
with this video.
So in this case this
is a video about--
I'm sorry, let me
just refresh it.
This is not a good sign.
I can't believe this.
OK.
While that's coming up, so for
example, let's go to this one.
So this case, this is an ad for
one of our Google Firewalls.
We're basically just pulling
ads from our Google channel.
As you can imagine, videos
have a much higher rate
of copyright
infringement, et cetera.
So we're primarily using
our own Google content.
So in this case, we're
just showing you an ad of--
this is an example where context
is switching a lot, right?
It's an ad, so you can
imagine every three or four
seconds you switch context
pretty significantly.
And we basically-- the
key aspect is we're
showing you how this changes.
So for example, what you
can do is basically draw
a list of all the entities
that are in this video.
So, for example,
in this case this
is primarily our entire JSON
dump of every single entity
that we detected.
We tell you the shot level,
video level about this entity.
The one gap we have
here is, for example,
because it's changing
context so much,
our video level entities
don't add a lot of value.
Does it make sense?
Because it's such a--
you can imagine which
things from outside
to inside and a lot of
things changing around.
Over time you can imagine as
we improve our video models
and we start taking
in additional signals
through our reader models, we
can pick up additional signals
to make our reader
classifier more smart.
And that's something we
are constantly working on.
So in this case, for
example, we find a car.
We tell you exact-- there's a
shot boundary where the car is.
And the other aspect
is, for example, we
see homes, a lot of
different pieces that's
flying around here.
The other thing
is, for example, we
know in that aspect
we're actually in the car
because the scene
is changing so fast.
So the video will
actually think we're
in a car and kind of
driving, that scenario.
So [INAUDIBLE] so you can
imagine common scenarios.
So our use case is
where we drive that.
So let me see if I can
come back to this case.
So in this case, this
is a video about what's
going on inside a zoo, right?
The entire video is actually
happening inside the zoo.
It's a nice friendly
video about animals.
So in this case our
video level entities
actually makes a lot of sense
because we're not changing
context for the entire time.
Our context is a
homogeneous video
about a tour of a
potential wildlife thing.
So we can actually find out
it's about a zoo, it's wildlife,
it's tourism, it can give you
much more relevant video level
entities in this case.
But we also can do things
like shot level entities.
So in this case, we can
look at these pieces,
and you can imagine each
of the slices are shots.
Again, this is an ad, so
the shots in this video
are changing constantly, right?
You're going to go every
five/six seconds is
changing a lot on you.
And so you can imagine as
we go from shot to shot
we start telling you all the
different pieces that flow in.
And a couple of things
that's relevant if you
think about digital
marketing scenarios, right?
It's a zoom video,
but there are a lot
of things about mobile
phones and devices in there.
So if you really kind of
mine the data to see what
are all the entities in there.
This is a great way to kind of
capture all that information.
Because you would
never have thought,
why would I see a mobile
device in my zoo video?
So here is another
aspect of a long video.
For example, in this
case, it's actually
a video of [INAUDIBLE] giving
a speech at a conference.
And this is an example for
where the number of shots--
and this is actually
not that many, right?
There's a lot of
shots, for example,
in this case she's
actually standing in one
place for pretty much for all.
She's just-- the video
follows her for a full minute.
And so you imagine there's
really no shot changes in that.
So it's actually just
about her talking.
So you can imagine
where a frame level
annotation in this context
would be extremely noisy,
because you're just
going to get bombarded
with 60 frame annotations
that tells you
exactly the same thing.
It's not really
relevant anymore.
And that's why shot level
aggregation is going
to be useful in that aspect.
And that's also a
unique proposition
from the video
perspective, we think,
compared to some of our
competitors in the marketplace
today.
So that's one aspect.
So what can you do
with all this metadata?
And as I said, my goal
is always to come back
to saying if you go
back to the scenario
on how we talked
about structured data,
how do we enable these things
in really structured data?
All of this is just JSON
that's flowing through, right?
So you can imagine we can start
basically making this JSON
and flatten this JSON.
It's as simple-- you can take as
JSON out, flatten it, and then
load it into BigQuery.
And now that it's in
BigQuery I can do things.
I can just write a
regular SQL query
like I would do everything else.
So now I want to understand,
for example, in this SQL
query all I'm trying to
do is, hey, tell me off
of all the shots
what's the most common.
By scene, what's the
most relevant entity
in all my shots.
So I can do a simple
SQL query, come back,
get that information out.
So really what I'm
trying to do here
is I've basically taken
all this video metadata,
taken all that, plugged
it, did the video API,
and brought it back into
BigQuery and run SQL queries.
As I said, the world
revolves around SQL.
Nobody got that joke.
So I've been in SQL for a while.
Here is another example of that.
So this is kind
of things that you
could imagine you can easily
do with the video intel.
That's really the value
that we're trying to do,
is we're trying to start making
sense of all this metadata
that you have in
your organization.
If you think about it, you now
have petabytes and petabytes
of media content.
You can run it through
Video Intelligence,
start harnessing those entities,
flow it into a database,
and start to actually
think about how
you can now index
your videos more
intelligently, feed it to
your media portals, fitted
to your query
engines, do analytics.
Think about scenarios
where you can now
correlate your entities in the
video to potentially ratings.
So you can figure out when
certain shows are going bad
based on ratings,
or can find which
entity were people looking at.
You can start doing more
interesting scenarios.
Now that you have
this as metadata
you can do a lot more
interesting scenarios
on the correlation, driving
the downstream, mission-only
models, et cetera.
Back to slides.
So with that, I want to ask
Juhyun to come on stage.
Juhyun's going to talk
a little bit about some
of the underlying technology
that we're doing, and also
talking about where
we're thinking
of taking it down the way, too.
JUHYUN LEE: All right.
Hi.
Let's go back.
So hi, I'm Juhyun from the
Video Intelligence team.
I'm a software engineer
in motion perception,
which is an organization
under Google research.
And our mission is to
make machines understand
unstructured data such as video,
audio, images, and et cetera.
I'm here to explain what's
going on under the hood
so that it doesn't look
like the wall of Google
is selling black
magic to consumers.
So given a video
in your GCS bucket,
the first thing that we
do is we decode the video.
And usually a video
container contains
like audio stream,
video stream, subtitles,
and all of the metadata.
And we are first interested
in the video stream.
And a video stream
is often a sequence
of images, a lot of them.
For a five-minute video at 24
frames per second you will have
like 7,000/8,000 images in them.
And they will probably in
sequence look a lot similar.
So classifying each of those is
not too efficient, let's say.
So we shot sample the
images, and say at one FPS.
So one frame per second we
apply an image classifier,
an image classifier
that is very similar
that you can get through
the Google Cloud Vision API.
And we do it for every
image in the entire video.
And for each frame, you
will get image features
such as this elephant with
97% accuracy, or animal,
or river in that case.
And if you keep
going on, you will
get like other labels
for crocodiles and lions.
And at the end of
the video what we do
is we have an aggregating
video classifier,
and this is really
what sits at the core
of this particular API.
And given all these features,
throughout the entire video
it will then say, A,
this is a documentary
about animals in Africa.
Another similar
example would be if you
have a video of people
in costumes or pumpkins
and candies, this classifier
will be able to tell you,
hey, this is a video
about Halloween.
And this is only
possible because we
have trained this model on
millions of YouTube videos,
and human rated and
also like verified.
Ram also talked about also the
shop level annotation a minute
ago.
And those are essentially
treating each shot
as a mini video, and then
running with the same logic.
Of course, there's more machine
learning and computer vision
techniques involved
in this, I am just
very briefly summarize this.
But you are essentially
getting what's behind YouTube
and photos with this release.
So far I've only talked
about the visual features,
but we are also considering
adding audio or motion
or speech or subtitles
to this classifier,
and do a final fusion in
this aggregating classifier.
So that you don't assume that
you have a video of an animated
music video.
It will be sad if we
give you a label saying
that it's an animated cartoon.
You definitely want your
audio signal in there.
So we are looking at
various audio signals
to improve the
quality of the model.
And one thing that I wanted to
emphasize is with this release,
we are not keeping
the models as is.
We are constantly improving the
model, especially when Google
internally releases a new
model for the YouTube photos,
then we also update the models
for Google Cloud video API.
And also your
feedback is important.
Your feedback may make
me happy or not so happy.
Those are incorporated
in the next releases.
So yeah, feel free to
reach out to us to improve.
All right.
Yeah, that's about leaking the
secret recipe that we have.
Now I'm going to talk a
little bit about what's
coming next, a preview
on video previews,
also known as a video
summaries or thumbnailer.
So assume that you have a
bunch of customer videos
and you have to
show it in a list,
you need to make a listing page.
Now you need thumbnails
for each of those videos.
How do you pick the right
video frame for the video
that you don't know about?
You could pick the first
frame in the video,
or you could apply the
Wadsworth Constant,
and skip to 30 second--
30% HD video and
then show that frame.
At Google we use
machine learning.
And what we do is we have a
machine learned classifier that
tells what's interesting-ness
of this particular video
frame as a thumbnail.
So we ran it through a
lot of YouTube videos,
human rated and also
verified, these are actually
positive with AB testing.
And, yeah, so here
on the screen you
can see videos, the link to
the YouTube video actually.
And in the middle column
you see a static thumbnail.
So the single frame that has the
highest interesting-ness score.
And on the rightmost column
you see moving thumbnails.
What's the most interesting
three second clip of that video
based on the machine classifier?
For example, let's show
earth view in Google Maps.
So this is the video when Google
Maps released the earth view,
and that's the corresponding
static thumbnail
and the dynamic thumbnail.
So this is when we
announced the Cloud Vision
API in December of 2015.
The whole video is about
presenting what Cloud Vision
API can do, and a demo on this
small little Raspberry robot.
So it correctly picks up
on the interesting thing,
the only thing in the video,
or like the moving thumbnail.
One thing that
you may ask is why
is the static thumbnail not a
subset of the actual animation
on the right.
And that's because the
two classifiers are doing
completely different things.
For example the right-most
column also incorporates motion
in deciding should this be
the moving thumbnail or not,
therefore you cannot do
that in a static thumbnail.
So with that, let me hand it
back to Ram for more use cases.
[APPLAUSE]
RAM RAMANATHAN: If
you just go back
to one second on the right.
I think a couple of
things that I really
loved about this demo is that
this Cloud Vision API was
really all about the robot.
And the fact that it picked
up that the key thing about it
is actually about the robot,
the Raspberry Pi [INAUDIBLE]
robot that shows up, is
actually pretty unique.
Because it kind of
somehow figured out
that this video is
really about how
we think about Vision
API applying the robot
on a little Raspberry Pi.
And it figured out that that's
the most relevant thumbnails
to pick up.
It's actually, I mean, if you
think about this problem--
if you go back to the slides--
if you think about this problem
for a organization that's
building media
portals and people
are dealing with millions
of video content.
I mean, if you have petabytes of
content in your media archive,
how do you consume it?
And that's really what
we're thinking about,
how do we make life easier?
So the two use case I'm going to
spend some time talking about.
First is thinking about
content recommendation.
So what I mean by that?
So for example, you think of
us, think of this as a mini
YouTube, right?
It's really not YouTube in
a specific infrastructure,
but think of a YouTube.
Basically, you've got a set of
videos on Google Cloud Storage,
you want to start deriving
some metadata on this video.
It then flows into potentially
BigQuery to do some analysis,
and then does a bunch
of data analysts
to look at this content,
do some queries on that.
And then the drive
creates some features,
they feed it into a cloud ML
model to drive recommendations.
At the same time they're
collecting things
like fixed stream behavior
to drive the scenario,
and it kind of flows
through that thing.
So that's really thinking about
a very common recommendation
scenario.
Do people actually do that?
So here is a public
research paper
that YouTube published
some time back.
So in this case, think of
this video [INAUDIBLE].
This video [INAUDIBLE]
is based on billions
and billions and
billions of videos
that people load into YouTube.
And you and me as a
user come into YouTube
to figure out what
to watch, right?
So the first thing
people actually
do is something like
collaborative filtering where
they're really
thinking about, how
do I apply what's kind
of the set of hundreds
of potentially targets that
we can show to the end user?
So that's really where
people are thinking
about pretty sophisticated
TensorFlow based models
to really think about that
collaborative filtering
to drive that scenario.
Then the next thing is really
want to think about this,
how do I then do ranking.
So all of these potentially
hundreds of content,
what's the 25 that I show
to the end user right there?
That's where they apply
second cycle downstream search
models that then sort of do a
kind of scenario on ranking.
But a key aspect
to keep in mind is
to drive both these machine
learning models they need
to get video features to flow.
And they need metadata
on what the video is
about to do the recommendation.
Because the recommendation
is both user
behavior and metadata
about the video.
And how do you get
metadata about the video?
You have to use something
like Video Intelligence.
But that's another aspect.
The other big scenario
is media portal,
just take another example
from the world of--
thing is I have
millions of content.
I want to start exposing
content in a lot
of different interesting ways.
How do I do that?
That's where some of the things
that Juhyun just pointed out
on thumbnails, around all
kinds of moving images
really start coming into
play on video summaries.
You just can't show a
two by three pixellation
view of any video and expect
people to click on it.
What you really want to do start
enticing them to click on that.
How do you entice them
to click on a video?
You have to show what's relevant
in the video as a thumbnail,
because people are
drawn visually.
They're going to first
look at something
and then read the captioning.
Very few people are going
to read the captioning first
and then look at an image.
So you want to make sure you're
showing the most relevant image
of that video, and then you
want an easy way for someone
to get a feel for what
that video is about.
That's why those
things on moving images
come into play,
because you really
want a way for our end user
to kind of over our over video
and get a really quick glance
of what this video is about.
And then you draw them
to the actual video.
That's why these
kind of techniques
when you think about building
media portals, video previews,
really start coming to play.
With that, what I want
to do is [INAUDIBLE]
talk about recommendations,
media portals.
There are lots of
other scenarios
that we want to
enable with this,
but you think about a lot of
customers thinking about how
they drive media workflows.
One of our customer
reference is [INAUDIBLE].
So they're really thinking
about how to use metadata
from these videos.
They drive it into their
media workflow engine.
So they enabled media publishers
and media organizations
to drive media workflows based
on entities that flow in.
One other customer who's
going come on stage earlier,
is wix.com.
Wix is one of our
favorite customers.
They've been with Google
Cloud platform for many years.
They were also an early partner
with us in the Vision API.
They are part of our
journey vision API.
They were actually
on stage same time
last year at GCP
Next. we were talking
about how do you use Vision API
to drive interests in scenarios
in their organization.
But as they're looking about
the launch of their new media
portal with Wix media
platform, they've
also been an early adopter of
our Video Intelligence API.
So with that, I'd like to invite
Lynne Hurwitz from wix.com
to talk about how they're
using Video Intelligence
in their organization.
LYNNE HURWITZ: Thank you.
Thank you very much, Ram.
It's a pleasure to be here.
My name is Lynne.
I'm a developer at
Wix, and I'd like
to start with a quick question.
How many engineers
would you think
it takes to create
a great website?
Very good.
The answer is zero,
if you're using Wix.
For those of you who don't
know Wix, let me explain.
Wix is a company
that allows everyone
to create their own great
website providing them
with the simplest
tools to do so.
Now, in this day
and age, in order
to have a really great
website what you need to do
is to have high quality
media in it and a lot of it.
Now, what Wix has to do also is
support our whole 100 million
users who upload
millions and millions
of files each and every day.
So as you can imagine, in
order to support all this,
in order to process all this
we need a very, very strong
infrastructure.
And we did develop one.
We call it the Wix
Media Platform.
This is what I'm going to
talk to you about today.
I'm going to tell you how
you can use it not only
Wix, each and every
one of you can use it,
everyone can use it.
And I'm going to tell you how
you can build your own media
portal on top of it.
So for example, meet Felix.
He's a chef,
entrepreneur, who wants
to build the next big thing.
Now he has this
great idea to build
a platform in which
people gather up,
study, and teach how to cook.
So he decided to do it
with a Wix Media Platform.
First things first,
his whole platform
is so focused on users.
So obviously he would
like to have user profiles
and he'd like to have
profile images in them.
Now, from his experience, he
does know this kind of thing
requires file upload,
image manipulation.
And he was really happy to see
that with a Wix Media Platform,
it does everything for him.
You can upload, using the media
platform, every kind of file,
specifically images, of course.
And when you actually
upload an image
it automatically goes
through the image API,
through the Vision API.
Now the Vision API
generates different labels
for this image.
I'll talk about that later.
And also it can detect
faces from the picture.
When you already have the face
detection, now all left to do
is just have the
image manipulation.
In this case, we're going to
use the Wix Media Platform image
manipulation tool.
This tool allows you to do
pretty much every operation you
probably know from Photoshop.
But you do it on the fly.
So what we do here
is pretty simple.
We just crop the
image, resize it,
and bam you have your picture
and it's ready for use.
Now, I'll take a minute just now
to stop everything and explain
what's going on
around behind me.
As you can see, we're in the
Wix Media Platform dashboard.
And you can see that we are
looking at demo widgets.
This is that playground
image manipulation widget
that is actually made by Wix.
Wix is using it in
order for you guys
to try it out, see the
features of the platform,
but it's obviously
more something
to do with Wix's needs.
Obviously everyone
who uses this platform
can decide what kind of
feature he wants to show out
and how he wants to show them.
So this is only an example.
As you can see
here, on the left,
you can see the different
manipulations you can do
and everything,
and under the image
you can see this HTML tag.
Probably a little
small, but what it does
is reveals the rest API
used by our platform.
You have also different SDKs,
more sophisticated SDKs,
that you can actually do a
lot with our platform with.
In this case, Felix
used the JavaScript SDK.
And as you can see, in
order to accomplish all
we talked about he
only had to write
these three lines of code.
Now, to the next big feature
of the system, video tutorials.
He wants his cooks to be
able to upload videos.
We already know the platform
allows that, OK, we have
image upload, any file upload.
But the real nice thing
about the media platform
is how easy it makes
it to work with videos.
You see, the
platform provides you
with everything you'll
ever need for a video,
especially if what you want
to do is to create a portal,
a media portal.
What it does is
transcode the video
to two different
qualities for you.
It creates a short tutorial from
the highlights in the movie,
and also it creates
poster images for you
from different
scenes in the movie.
Now, I'm really excited to say
that the Video Intelligence API
made it so much better for us.
Because up until
now, we actually
made these poster images from
random places in the video.
But now, thanks to the
Video Intelligence,
we can know what are the
main scenes in the movie
and we can just take the
main picture from them.
So we have the main poster
images, most relevant ones,
which is great.
So now when we have our
videos up and running, yay,
we have everything
ready to go, right?
Not quite.
We're still missing something.
How can we allow our users
to enjoy the content?
Think about it, we're going
to have such a huge platform.
We are going to have such
many tutorials in it.
How can they find the
relevant content for them?
So obviously, as you see,
we need a search capability.
Now, thanks to the
Video Intelligence API,
once again we have every
time we transcode a video,
we also pass it through
the Video Intelligence API.
Now this Video Intelligence
API, as you can see,
provides us with relevant
labels for the video.
Now, this is great because
our platform obviously
has the metadata for
every file you upload,
but using the metadata
and the labels together,
and we have a great
search capability
on top of the Wix
Media Platform.
Now the next thing about
this, because we're eventually
using Wix, it's also
supported in SEOs.
So different search engines
can also see these results.
Now when we have a search
capability in our system,
a nice way to show
it would be using
the poster images we have.
So Felix here uploaded
a video tutorial
of spaghetti balongese.
And he has these poster
images generated out of it.
Now imagine someone searches for
Italian cuisine or spaghetti.
How can we find the best
fitting poster image for him?
Well, remember I told you
images go through the Vision API
and have labels
extracted for them?
Well, here we go.
So we take these
labels, see our labels
from the Video Intelligence
API, match them, and that's it.
We can have the
best fitting poster
image for our search results.
Now, another great feature
powered by the Video
Intelligence API and
I think is extremely
important is safe search.
Felix here does not know
obviously all the users in his
platform, and cannot control
the content they upload.
But he can still be
very calm and know
he has full control
in his system,
because the media platform
would mark any offensive content
uploaded.
That means he can just
decide what he does with it.
He can let it go, he
can mark it, maybe add
a warning for the users,
or maybe even filter it out
whatsoever.
It's his decision to make.
Last but not least, now
Felix would like everyone
to enjoy the content.
So this is already
taken care of.
Wix Media Platform takes care
of hosting and serving files
flawlessly, no matter
where your users are,
no matter what
device they're using.
This is thanks to the
Google CDN, of course.
Now that's pretty
much it for Felix,
but I do want to remind you
this is only an example.
The Wix Media Platform
as a powerful versatile
tool that every one of
you can use yourselves.
It allows you to
manage your data,
to have image manipulation,
video transcoding,
to tag and label your data,
and make it searchable
also supporting SCOs, and it
serves your data flawlessly.
The platform provides you
with unlimited possibilities.
I invite you to use it,
and I'm looking forward
to see what great
things you will build.
Check us out on
gcp.wixmp.com, and also
today in the Google
Cloud Launcher.
Thank you very much.
RAM RAMANATHAN: Thank you.
Perfect.
So coming back to kind
of key use cases--
going back to the key
use cases we talk about
from video perspective.
Really want to help you find
the main topics from a media
perspective.
What the video is
about, when the video
did something awkward.
Drive things around in
inappropriate content,
and really thinking
about how you
can start highlighting
the video,
things are on thumbnails,
video previews, et cetera.
So really these are the
kind of key use cases
we're going after now, but it
doesn't mean that we're not
looking at other use cases.
We're constantly
evolving the product.
And part of what we
call our private beta
is to get more feedback
from folks like yourselves
to start playing with the API
so you can tell us what else
to add.
What are the gaps?
What are the things-- that's
kind of really why we're
trying to go through these
private beta for people
to give us feedback and
start evolving the product.
So you can join
the private betas,
just go to
cloud.google.com/video
intelligence.
You just kind of go
there, and then you
can basically the
alpha and we screen
and start on-boarding
folks next week.
Basically, once I get back home.